The joe rogan experience.
They like described Brendan Schaub.
Oh,
the lips.
He's big lift.
I describe his big brown.
That's medium.
Got On and on Twitter trying to get his name.
I'm trying to get his nickname change from hybrid to big Brown.
This guy starts with big,
broad,
big brown.
He's big brown.
He's just big and Brown.
That's why everybody calls him big brown bats.
It's weird when you see someone come home,
your Stepdad,
Gus,
it's got our lock.
I want,
what
if I was breaded sharp?
It'd be like for sure.
Keep your hands up next time for sure.
Don't let them get that close to you.
Talk my shit to each other.
They get in a fight when I was 12 I'm not making this up.
Whatever.
Fucking cars.
Right.
My Dad pulls in front of them.
He pulls it from my dad.
He gets out of my day goes,
you want to fucking go?
My Dad's like,
oh no.
Like an old school Irish boxer.
Oh No.
I remember being like 10 or 11 being like,
ah,
fuck man.
See the problem with that is Nick Diaz can actually fight like that.
Oh my dad be his breaks off this dude.
Yeah.
It was about to throw him off the side of the highway and a leather jacket.
No,
I did not fuck around when a guy stands out like that,
so that's doing the old school boxing and one of two things can happen.
He's trying to scare you off or he's so good with his hands.
He's just kind of roll out.
You're like,
what's up dude?
You want some?
Yeah,
man.
he was weird.
I'll tell you what,
for real man,
I remember my dad got in the car.
I'm like,
God dammit.
And then my brother gets out,
kicks guy in the balls from behind,
but others probably 12 at the time he's this Christ brother kicked a grown man
and the role of men in the balls,
but that's when it gets really dangerous because that kid gets involved.
Father becomes like super violent.
Little Brown was doing what was crying in the backseat.
How old were you?
Probably like 10 or 11 crying in the backseat seat.
Can't be trusted if shit goes down because you gotta remember my daycare was
Shane Carbon on top of me.
I wasn't getting a lot of take downs.
I was on my back all the time.
That's a crazy way to start your training in MMA.
It was horrible,
horrible mess.
So crazy.
Every day.
Just beat me up.
Trevor Whitman seems like a crazy dude,
man.
He's a good dude.
I mean he was like a very good dude.
Good guy.
I haven't been there in years.
The maniac like he had Shane Carwyn.
Um,
like why they wanted to have Shane Carwyn sport spar with GSP.
GSP was like,
what?
Yeah,
why would I,
why?
Why would I spar him?
Like what are you talking about?
And I think Trevor's a genius becomes a strike and stuff like that.
But I think back on it and there's this thing where I felt like I had to prove
to everyone I could hang with Shane car and no matter when we were sparring,
that's how my footwork got so good.
Cause I'm,
I'm used to this giant water buffalo mad water buffalo chasing me around the
octagon.
So I was trying to get out of the way cause he landed right hand.
It was a short him,
he was not a good man is trouble.
He hit so hard,
he's got so,
so I got used to that right.
And I'm moving nonstop and then when the bell goes,
Ding,
Ding with 30 seconds left,
literally,
no matter what we're doing,
I mean Shane would stop,
walk to the middle of the cage and just rock 'em sock 'em robots.
Damn.
I did that for three years.
And then finally a part of me was like,
uh,
how about no?
And I shot a double back on him and we've never done that again.
Yeah,
I'm tired.
But I think back on my training,
I'm like,
God,
that was stupid.
Even taking them down.
I mean,
he's so strong and he's a big Guy Guy.
Ever did a big fucking guy,
man.
Strong.
A lot stronger than you and your strong Shane is 100% stronger than me.
Not even close.
He's ridiculously strong.
Bone structure is just,
he's bigger than car.
He's bigger than Lesner.
He's legs are thick,
thick ass,
huge shoulders.
He's hands man.
Before they did,
they redid the UFC gloves to fit over his hands.
Shane's the reason Shane's,
the reason why they changed the glove,
Shane had a five XL gloves.
You have to cut the glove just to get over to his hands are so ridiculous.
Yeah.
When you shake them,
it's like holding onto a ham.
What was frustrating to me is,
you know,
I've always been in love with Jujitsu.
I would spend,
Shane would get injured or you'd have to work at a regular job and I was just
train full time and I would think I was being so good at Jujitsu.
Then Shane would come in off a nine to five,
you know,
shift Walkin by Jujitsu Hunt,
let's do it.
And I'm like,
I'm going to roll this big dude.
You just shut,
shut it all down.
When I was training at a malls,
he came by and uh,
and,
and trained one day and uh,
I didn't get to roll with them,
but uh,
I watched people row with them and it was,
it was like a child playing with his daddy.
Daddy was just like rolling over.
I go with big guys.
I go the big guys all the time,
but none like Shane,
man,
he doesn't even look real when he walked in the door.
If I didn't know,
I was like,
what's up Shane?
But if I didn't know what I would be like saying a peep this motherfucker,
he's got legs grown out of his shoulders.
This is how it happened.
I was like,
oh,
I want to be a fighter.
I had knew Nate mark cart.
I looked him up online,
found out where his academy was in Aurora,
my hometown.
I show up there.
Nate's a great guy,
right?
He's like,
yeah man,
well we can do,
we can do this.
We'll figure it out.
Come tomorrow.
There's another big guy.
He just,
he only has like one fight.
He just started fighting and he played football too.
I'm like,
oh,
cool.
I show up.
It's spine,
right?
I show up and in watching current,
the time is 315 lbs.
Fighting the WC just jacked look like a silver back gorilla that just found the
weight room and does nothing else.
Just remember that when he was really that big,
there's a picture of him that doesn't even look real.
It's insane.
And Nate,
Nate goes,
Oh hey,
here's the guy wanted to,
yes you do introduce you to.
And uh,
since then me and Shane sparred and we just stood toe to toe and neither one of
us knew what we were doing,
blasting each other.
You rolled with guys,
I mean you had the biggest and the baddest as a training partner forever.
The best man.
While he was like a little brother and when I couldn't afford private training
with Trevor Whitman and chain blue to me so much,
he paid for my training with Trevor,
for Shane having a guy like you around and valuable,
you know,
trying to find a giant pictures cause me and him in Normandy,
Emilia,
I think one or two fights at the time had zero.
The Machita fight,
he was,
it was close wide.
That was a close fight.
I just thought,
what do you think it was about?
Was just rumbled.
Just too is a monster.
It's just too much of a monster monster.
Rumble's a scary guy.
Pops,
kid heavyweight.
God,
it's so crazy.
Almost stopped him in the first round.
He broke his John Half and the first round like,
or I'll ask you fought the last two rounds with a John that was shifting up and
down cause it was shattered in the side.
Somebody who's fighting our last game,
he's got some good stories.
When we talk about how guys are hyping fights,
it can backfire on you.
Like Yo with the metro and fight.
Me and Matt,
uh,
you know we're buddies where we can both talk a little smack.
So it was good to hype the fight talking smack,
right?
It was great.
When you fight legends like Mirko Cro,
Cop,
Andre Arlovski,
big Nog with our [inaudible] fans or hit me up on Twitter like,
oh,
I can't wait to see what your smack talk is.
There's no smack talk.
I don't need to talk smack the Andre you to hype this fight.
He's a legend.
You're not going to win any fans over.
What are you going to say?
Oh man,
you fucked the very best fighters in the world.
You're a heavyweight champ,
you know what I mean?
What are you gonna do you gotta be super respectful man.
Otherwise they fucking attack like whoa.
Like it did the fund itself.
But tell him,
tell him the story about how,
how you wrote your,
a training with our Lasky after,
for after training where he's,
he goes,
come here.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
Andrea Alaska and I used to train together Jackson's camp and when I was getting
ready for a fight this over shoot almost four years ago,
the two fighters that I,
when I first got into the game that I admired and loved where Mirko Cro,
cop and Andre are Laski by two very favorites.
That's who I wanted to be like.
So I walked in the gym and it was our last keys first day at Jackson's too.
And uh,
you know,
when you seen a guy on TV fighting all the time,
then you run into and be like,
damn,
all right.
So I see him like,
Oh shit,
this under Lasky.
So then that guy [inaudible] our last year in the ring,
uh,
first day spine,
right,
fresh off the plane.
When I'm sparring with him.
So me and him are gone and it's a,
it's a close round.
He's a bad ass right at me and we're going back and forth.
People would literally stop and watch a spar were just these dog rounds back and
forth,
five rounds in a row.
Then later that night we grapple and then,
uh,
the next morning I drink coffee every morning,
right?
Drinking coffee now this horrible coffee breath,
breath smelled like pure coffees.
Shit breath.
Right.
And I go up to Andre and he's not very warm person at all.
Not at all.
Is that very bell rush in where it's going to take a while to be his friend.
I can tell and I'm trying to break these barriers.
Van,
I go,
hey bro,
I just want to let you know,
man.
I got the coffee breath and he,
uh,
he didn't say a word to me the night before.
Training goes,
it's okay.
It's okay.
Much better than yesterday.
Yesterday.
Shit.
Cool black.
He goes yesterday,
breast smelled like Shit.
Oh,
cool man.
Cool.
And then just went about our business.
That was really the only words he ever said to me,
man.
And we trained together for a while.
It wasn't even like framing.
What about when you were kicking,
when he had you kick his body?
Yeah.
And then we done training.
I've never done this.
He goes,
ah,
I'm trying to do my best Russian accent it,
you guys are pretty much terrible rush.
Nice.
Horrible.
Right.
Okay.
Sorry,
I'm not from Russia.
The bus,
he goes out,
he goes,
put your hands on top of your head like this.
And I'm like,
what are we doing?
And we just got done sparring.
I'm exhausted,
right?
I put my hands up and he just goes braced herself and starts wailing at my body.
Why?
With kicks punches Waylon.
It was this,
this make you tough.
My okay.
And I'm like,
oh,
I'll try to be tough though cause he's my hair.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
Wow.
And then he goes,
my turn,
you do it to me.
And I'm like,
dude,
he goes,
no,
you hit like girl hit and I'm fucking trying man.
Trying to hurt this guy.
Nothing.
And that was my experience with Andre Arlovski.
I'm a day cutting and baby Dick Sense.
I don't know anything about cutting,
cutting,
sucking baby deck,
all that Moses,
when he cut his own penis to show his Serbians to God in the Old Testament.
That's a very weird way to show your speed speaking.
But you're at a friend break a Dick Moses.
I heard of that before.
I've had a friend break.
A Dick had rush from the emergency room
fixed.
Totally.
Or is it always kind of hooked it Kinda,
yeah.
Curves to the left a little bit.
Wow.
His balls literally internal bleeding filled up.
Oh my look like purple Gecko skin.
That's why you gotta be kept careful with crazy bitches.
You got to get double under hook.
Some crazy bitch.
I do my bit crazy.
Bitches riding you.
You gotta.
You gotta hold their ass.
But like a from [inaudible].
You know how you got to go plum.
You can't just do this because if you do this,
there's too much lateral room.
There's room for down.
I got to get a study.
Gable grip.
The lower hips.
My buddy is huge.
You've met this guy,
I'm not going to say his name on there.
These guys,
six,
six to 70 sram ways wait,
people are going to figure out who they won't figure it out is so he's like,
he tells me,
he goes,
Bro,
this girl wants it so hard.
He goes,
I don't know what to do,
how hard.
He goes,
I'm going to film it next time.
So he films it and it's one of the most disturbing videos I've ever seen.
I mean,
he's getting air like,
why am I'm like,
Dang.
Later he calls me,
he goes,
dude,
get over here.
I rush over.
What's the man?
He's on the ground,
but button they go like,
what's the values?
That video I showed you,
I was backing up,
missed my penis,
hit her ass,
broke his dick.
Oh my God.
So this is what I tell him.
I go,
Bro,
this is an easy fix,
right?
I,
I've,
I'm,
I have no idea how to hand this doctor.
Shab yeah,
doctor shop in the house.
Big brown.shop in the house.
I know this easy fix.
I'm going to step out of the room.
You put a little porno on,
you get erect.
We are just going to line it right back,
right back up.
Just like he fix a broken nose.
That's a great strategy,
right?
Make sense?
That's a great shot out of the room.
10 minutes later I hear it.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
So I call my doctor buddy.
I'm like,
Yo man club my,
my buddy was hooking up with this girl,
broke his stick.
He goes,
well,
is there like you're as TESCO's big?
Oh yeah,
man,
they're pretty big.
Let see your task goes,
man,
shows me these things are the size of a grapefruit and it looks like ghetto
purple dotted scam all over la rush,
rush in the emergency room cause internal bleeding.
And uh,
people thought we were just to gays
gay math.
Big dudes.
I'm not making this up.
I wish I could make this up.
He straddled in a Gurney like this,
right?
He's like this things hanging down.
It's filling up,
talking to this nurse comes in,
hey boys,
flaming,
flaming gay guy,
right?
Which is whatever.
I'm cool with that.
Legs up in style.
If this is his broken penis,
this dude's like this.
Hmm,
yeah,
yeah.
This is pretty bad.
Listen,
we get a doctor and we'll be right back.
He's doing that to his boss and I'm like,
what is going on here?
Leaves doc comes in,
old dude.
I'm like,
oh,
thank God.
Dot comes in.
He goes,
yeah man,
this is really bad.
Or yeah,
the,
the nurse was Kinda,
uh,
you know,
he's grabbing a man and it's insane how badly he goes,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
A nurse physically touched his penis,
touched
telescope nose deep in his,
on his dick.
And he goes,
wow,
I need to get the name of that guy because that is not code here.
Dick [inaudible] got an app on his phone and when anybody gets administered to
the hospital with a broken deck,
he fucking shows up,
puts her hands,
this,
you're all just comes in.
And I go,
I gotta be honest,
man.
How did you get into basically majoring in Dick's?
Like what road did you go down and he said in Egypt there's someplace in Egypt
where there's a religion.
They might be Muslim,
I'm not sure.
But they get erections.
They think it's Dell,
the Satan's work.
And they break their dad's not in.
That's not Muslim religion.
That might be,
well no,
it's an extremist Muslim.
He was saying there are Muslim just sounds like a dumb person who this look the
whatever it is.
It's another crazy cause he was saying and these guys need help.
So he got into it because he was exposed to it.
So these guys think it's Satan's work.
The Devil's work.
They'd get erections,
snap their day.
A lot of them die from internal bleeding.
He,
they brushed doctors down there.
So most urologists go down to this part of the world.
That's a fix it.
Anyways,
my buddy,
a break,
he's all good.
Now the update of my friend,
all good.
They give him pills so he couldn't get an erection for six weeks and his dick
was in a splint.
Really?
A splints.
Splints and it has a hook.
Yeah.
So White Hook or a big one notice.
Oh,
it's definitely knows.
What are you a,
it'd be a little hyperbole there.
May never seen one of reports.
How about that?
Fuck all.
Haven't I didn't man.
Swear to God.
I have never seen her.
Not One.
You've never seen her work.
How dare you not do research for that episode?
Yeah.
Well I know she's,
I went,
yeah,
she does some heavy shit too.
Oh,
and almost too much where you go.
Okay,
well that can't be well on my podcast.
She said her skin was bad because she was taken in her vermin.
Tom Said,
I think you're taking in too much testosterone.
Too many loads.
Yeah.
She's got a whore on your hands
or be off casting.
You.
Imagine if you take it so many loads that it changes your biological profile.
You imagine if you're just dating a girl,
she had come my fucking face keeps breaking out.
What's happening?
He's fucking guys busted all over my face,
man in her.
Oh,
you're in just so much come in her body probably annually.
A lot of it.
Yes,
and orally.
I don't that doesn't make that noise when I'm coming unless I'm fighting.
Yeah,
I've never had that noise.
There's some hot about that though.
I would agree with you with asa.
I agree.
I like a turbo slut and so I always have always will do most of contact asa and
have her print up that shirt
with glitter.
I'll bake you a shirt
Hashtag [inaudible] why don't we make them?
I'll wear turbo
turbo slept.
I guarantee you if you guys put out a turbo sweat shirt fell out to ask.
Give for the girl limited edition for women.
You don't have the balls.
I say dude,
you can fucking limited edition.
Just make 20 they'll sell instantly when he have him.
20 tweets we get now about terrible Fletcher.
Well yes I agree were terrible so it's a great great word.
Was breaks funny Cherwell slash sled or is it just turbo?
Turbo slow?
It's a great designation.
Is it one word or two words?
Two words I guess.
Terrible schools do hashtag turbo slash Hash Hashtag turbo slot.
Oh Turbo slut.
That's going to like anything that happens in the news now from now on,
Hashtag turbos anytime a girl does something fucked up.
Hashtag [inaudible] her about sled grilled cheese on man turbo slot.
Patrick Terry.
Most can work for guys too and make that t shirt on.
Ag.
Terrible slot.
I like it for,
we don't have any women.
We don't know.
That's more of a guy's day.
All right.
You think so?
Tank top.
What?
Girls get away?
Material Science guys will buy for their girl.
You don't think Austin would wear it?
Yeah.
Okay.
We got one sale in the market and making money.
Every girl that suicide,
the suicide girls talk cash doctor will slip.
I guarantee Whitney just for shits and giggles,
Whitney comes with when Whitney would not wear that,
she'd be at it said jokes.
She's more of a feminist when I'm parenting because it's funny and I disagree.
All right,
and I'm talking for her.
She'd probably be like,
shut up dude.
I don't know if it works.
Listen man,
I'll wear that.
How about we showed it on [inaudible] dot com all right,
we'll figure it out.
No problem.
Turbo slack,
Gay [inaudible] gay.com I like our website teeth.
He's walking.
What is your nationality?
My mom's full blooded English.
It's bullshit.
Born and raised in a year.
Patchy.
Born and raised in tuition.
That's German.
A little bit of town.
French,
native American and Jewish.
100% I don't care what anybody says.
You got some,
did you ever do you genome test to see if anybody's lying?
No.
I need to someone fucking the father.
[inaudible]
your dad looks exactly like the crying Indian from those commercials in the 70s
and I mean exactly.
And even got watery eyes by the way is the braids and the long hair.
Here's something to consider when someone talks about someone being German or
someone being Italian or someone being anything.
Um,
yeah maybe,
but who knows how they got to Germany or Italy 17 generations before.
Who knows where any of the manic people came from.
Does it all lead back to like some Africans?
Yeah.
Tell him what Tom.
Tell the story about,
well from about keep Kimbo slice Kimbo slice on ultimate fighter.
When you were guys were doing that,
they didn't even show this on there.
So this guy,
I'm not going to mention his name on the show,
he lost and you can drink all that alcohol you want in the house.
And there's only at the time there's only four of us left,
still fighting.
Roy Marcus Jones,
I'm Mitch [inaudible],
Mitch reone and uh,
myself.
That's the four fighting,
right?
So one of you guys,
one of the other guys is hammered,
hammered,
he's lost,
right,
hammered,
wasted.
All of a sudden this guy gets super racist in the house and there's a whole
bunch of black guys in the house.
Starts talking about how his wife loves him because the Indian nation and starts
throwing up racial slurs and throwing up these,
you know,
the hit,
Hey Hitler stuff.
Heil Hitlers died his name on this piece of paper for me.
All right dude,
dude,
this isn't getting out though,
right?
Need to know for my own edification.
So he starts doing all this stuff.
I'm sleeping,
I've the biggest fight of my life.
The next day,
Dana white literally stops us in the car and goes,
listen,
if whoever makes to the finale where we win or not,
you're gonna be a superstar.
It's huge,
man.
The biggest season we've ever had.
You guys want to win this fight.
Thank you.
No pressure.
So I'm sleeping and
I'm sleeping and uh,
I'm,
I'm sleeping on the ground and I thought it was a dream.
Kimbo slice and Marcus Jones and this and this demicco in this demicco Rogers,
uh,
comes in my room.
They go,
Yo,
shop.
Get up,
dog.
Get up man.
I'm like,
Huh,
why are there three large black guys run my bed?
Kim Goes,
Yo,
man,
this dude's down there talking about our people.
We're about to jack him up.
I literally,
I thought I was in gym.
I go,
excuse me.
It's talking about our people dog.
Let's go eff this dude up and like,
listen,
uh,
you guys realize I said,
I'm,
I'm told I'm not down with the race thing.
I'm totally down to fuck this dude up,
but you realize I'm not black,
right?
Kim Goes,
you ain't no baby.
Damn.
That's crazy.
Turn around and leave and I hear that's why a lot shop,
you can't tell what the hell he is.
I go,
Hey Kimbo that's racist dog years.
Wyo just cause I'm athletic and can file you gotta be black.
He goes,
you could be
okay.